Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
Thank you everyone who submitted questions for this week's Q&A.
I know there are a lot of questions about where they're taking things
given the changes they've already made.
I tried to address as many, you know, non-crazy-spoilery question as possible.
Double high-fives to everyone that submitted fan-subs too.
Some of you had some questions about how to do that.
So, I'll explain at the end of this video.
But, just, careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet.
So, here we go. First question.
Xiu asks:
"Am I the only one who doesn't trust Daario, I don't like his relationship with Daenerys."
Yeah, it looks like you're not a big fan of Ed Skrein, either.
I think that the new Daario is a better actor, too. Just in general.
The thing about him that made me really suspicious was how quick he was to trying to get Daenerys
to re-open the figting pits.
She thinks it's barbaric and subhuman.
It'll take a few more episodes to get some more evidence,
but I will freaking a little bit if he starts siding with Hizdahr.
Hizdahr, I think, is one with the agenda. But remember, Daario is a mirsinary. He can be bought.
We do see him trying to defend Daenerys in the trailer here, in Daznak's Pit.
So, I'm not expecting any like dramatic left-turns from the book version of Daario.
I think, it's most likely, they'll just cut out some of his plot. Just because he's not gonna be on screen quite as much.
Yeah, just keep your eyes peeled on Daario.
And if you're brave enough, you can keep them peel on his butt, too.
Because he's probably gonna spend most of this season naked.
Next question, Dandino asks:
"Which episode is it that will outrun the books?"
So, you're asking, like, "When will the show pass the books?"
I think it's gonna be different for each character.
I think, Sansa will be in Wind of Winter territory this year, so she's almost already past her book story.
Or even in the first episode.
Bran has already caught up with his WoW storyline.  Which is why they chose to omit him.
If Stannis marches for Winterfell before the end of the season
he'll have caught up with his WoW storyline too.
So, that could happen in the middle of the season, it could happen at the end.
Depending on how you look at the way they're changing the young Griff-Tyrion-Varys storyline
you could say that he's already passed his book story too.
But there's a lot he's doing right now, in book 5, in Dance with Dragons. So we'll see.
Next question, Billtang asks:
"Do you think we'll see Melisandre's illusion magic in the TV show?"
So, you're talking about Glamour magic.
I certainly hope we do. I mean, we've seen almost every other kind of magic.
For people who haven't read the books,
Jaqen H'ghar changing faces, the Faceless Men changing faces,
isn't the same thing as Glamouring.
From a visual perspective, it is.
Typically, Glamouring involves the Glamoured person using some sort of charm. Like a jewel.
So, Melisandre could Glamour someone, but she'd have to give them, like, one of her jewels.
This kind of gets into Mance Rayder stuff.
In after the episode, the creators almost unofficially confirmed that he is dead. Dead for good.
So, if they do end up Glamouring anyone on the show, it's gonna be a part of a storyline that's different from the books.
Next question, Ramin asks:
"How could Dany ever trust Varys when he was the one giving the small council in King's Landing information about her?"
I think, his meeting with her would involve an intermediary.
Like, he would be introduced to her through the group that is part of the Targaryen restoration.
I don't think he would just walk up to the base of the pyramid and say:
"Hello, my name is Varys, I used to sit on the Small Council. Please make me one of your advisers."
So what I'm hoping is, we meet some of these other people that Varys has been
plotting and scheming with.
That could be the Golden Company, they could tie the Dornish Master Plan to the Varys-Daenerys storyline.
It could be Doran Martell. He could be sitting at the top of that Targaryen restoration.
I don't think he's a giant fan of the Targaryens, I think he just hates the Lannisters.
Next question, Liam asks:
"Which character do you think they'll have to delve into WoW stuff for? I know Sansa will, but do you think there will be any major spoilers from the book in this season for other characters?"
I don't know about big spoilers because the show is changing so much stuff.
It depends on what you consider a spoiler.
I assuming most of the people asking about WoW type stuff are book readers,
who are worried that the show is going to spoil the books.
I'd say, at best, what the show is going to do, is just confirm a few fan theories.
And the rest of the stuff will just be a dramatic departures.
So, it won't even be close to what happens in the books.
It's like, the book travels in a straight line,
think of the show like, you know, following the line for a little bit, then going all the way around
and then coming back to, like, the point where the show ends up at.
That's actually gonna be a lot of fun this season.
Like, trying to figure out if the show confirms or does not confirm or, like, stomps on any big fan theories.
But just remember, the show is gonna be vastly different from the books.
In all, but like the biggest storylines.
Next question, Sariko asks:
"Since Brienne story line is connected to Lady Stoneheart, do you think they'll introduce us to her this season?"
I'm not expecting to see Lady Stoneheart.
I do think that we'll see some easter eggs for her. Like, some visual reminders.
I know Michelle Fairley's name appeared on the IMDb page for the finale.
But unless we get some more confirmation or see some more evidence,
I'm gonna assume that a fan did that, and that it was bogus.
Next question, TrueLoner asks:
"I have a question about Daenerys' dragons.
Do you think they were actually trying to harm her or would they ever harm or kill her if they could?"
No, I think they were just really pissed off.
Daenerys' dragons are still bonded to her.
Drogon, Viserion, Rhaegal, all bonded to her.
That hasn't changed.
But if you cage any kind of animal, it's gonna get pissed, if you don't let it out.
We have to assume that the dragons are being fed.
We don't know how much and we don't know what they're being fed.
So, they're probably upset about that, too.
It's like you've ever owned a large dog.
They're really sweet, but sometimes they get cranky.
So, that's what I think is going on with her dragons.
And if you believe that Targaryens can't be burnt by fire then she was never in any danger.
Although, to be fair, they could probably chew a Targaryen in half.
One of Daenerys' other big problems, in addition to her, like, people problem, is that
she doesn't know a lot about dragonlore.
That's where I think Tyrion and Varys can help out.
Just because they read a lot of books.
And that's where most of the contemporary knowledge of dragons comes from.
It's from old books that people wrote a long time ago.
Next question, Angel asks:
"What do you think about the character of Olly, the little boy from Castle Black, how do you think he'll be developed?"
Ok, so, this is actually a good question.
I saw a lot of people talking about this.
Olly was the one that killed Ygritte.
I think that Olly will be involved with John Snow's big WTF moment this season.
I don't wanna give away any huge spoilers.
But I think he's gonna be critical to that moment.
I think, it'll be a big twist on that season 4 moment.
Like, it'll be a big call back to that.
But, please, use spoiler tags if you're gonna comment on that. Just because it is pretty spoilery.
Next question, Bence asks:
"Why did Varys say that Robert was a disaster? I though through that time, he was a mighty warrior and honorable, but why disaster?"
So, you're talking about, as a king.
I think, it was just his overspending.
Remember, it'd been almost 16 years that he'd been king.
And he'd been having tournaments all that time, spending the Crown's money.
Spending them into a pile of debt, with the help of Little Finger.
So, he might not had been a terrible king, but he definitely hated ruling.
The administrative part of ruling.
Had someone, you know, with the mindset of Tywin been king, they might have been a little more mindful of
what all the little birds of King's Landing were doing around them.
Like, Little Finger's plan to destabilize the crown with crushing debt.
Next question, Karen asks:
"How did the first 4 episodes get leaked?"
That's a good question.
So, what happens is, HBO will give screeners to critics, to people that translate,
There's just a whole giant list of people who get episodes ahead of time.
So, someone in that sea of people took the screeners, then uploaded them to the internet.
Next question, John asks:
"Does Melissandre see something special in Jon Snow? She's been eyeing him up ever since they set foot on Castle Black."
Yeah, I definitely think that she sees a royal blood in him.
Remember what she can do with royal blood. There's power in royal blood.
So, she probably wants to use him to do something really powerful.
Most of you guys probably know that I'm a big fan of the R+L=J theory of Jon Snow.
As in, like, his parents are Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark.
That would give him, like, the most royal blood possible.
I don't know that you can quantify how royal different people's blood could be, different noble's blood,
but I think that his blood is more powerful than Stannis' is.
Which is why she's so interested in him.
Thank you so much, everyone, for submitting questions, these are always a ton of fun to do.
This is gonna be a really fun season.
I know, they'll be a lot of questions based on big changes they make.
But, that just more stuff for us to talk about.
Congratulation to the winners of the book giveaway.
The next round of the giveaway will start whenever I post my episode 2 video.
That'll be a subscription for HBO NOW. That'll be, like, what the weekly giveaway is.
For those who are asking about the fan-sub stuff.
If you look at the "CC" menu at the bottom of the player,
you go through that and it just says: "add subtitle" that's the menu where you do it.
Thank you so much again, everyone, who's been submitting fan-subs. It's a huge help to me.
And thank you for almost 30,000 followers on Twitter and 50,000 on Facebook.
If you do wanna follow me there, there are links for that in the description.
Sometimes I'll live-tweet shows if I'm not working on other videos.
My next bonus video is probably gonna be about the House of Black and White,
so I'll post that before my episode 2 review post on Sunday.
And just in case you guys haven't seen it yet
you can click here for my episode 1 video,
and you can click here to learn all about the Sons of the Harpy.
Thank you so much for watching, everybody, let's high-five! I'll see you, guys, tomorrow.